this right over here is a i guess you
could say it's a cross-sectional image
of a human brain and i probably don't
have to tell you that the brain is a
fascinating organ it's what makes you
you and me me everything that you or i
think about that we're doing we're
seeing it's really all occurring in the
brain even this reality that you see
around you that you think is external to
your brain it's really a a simulation
that your brain constructs for itself
based on sensory input from the outside
world so you can imagine it's this
incredibly complex and you could even
say mysterious organ
and even though we don't understand
everything about how the human brain
works and i can imagine we will be
exploring how the brain works and
learning more about it for decades if
not centuries to come there are things
that we do know about the human brain we
do know for example that it's made of
it's made up of the estimates i've seen
of anywhere it was roughly 80 to 100
billion let me write that in caps
billion
billion neurons
and neurons
are
the cells that essentially
do
all of the processing of our brain so
this right over here is a
is a if you were to kind of really zoom
in on the brain at a very very small
level this right over here is a
blow up of what a neuron looks like
there are other khan academy videos that
go in much more depth on the anatomy of
a neuron and the functions of a neuron
but you see here that you have a you you
have
it's a cell with a nucleus just like
other cells and what it does is
essentially receives input it receives
signals from other neurons and then when
it's stimulated accordingly it'll send
signals to other neurons and this
stimulation and inhibition and sending
signals from one neuron to another and
through kind of chem
chemoelectrical signals this is the
stuff of our thoughts our thoughts are
these these continuous stimulations and
innovation inhibitions from one neuron
to another from one neuron to another
neuron it's not you know when you're
thinking a thought or you're looking at
a dog or you're trying to solve an
algebra problem
it's not just one or two neurons that
are firing we're talking on the order of
of of thousands or millions or or maybe
even billions of neurons firing and you
have kind of these
these
impulses that are traveling through your
brain depending on the connections that
you're forming the associations that
you're you're forming in the concept
that you're looking at and these
connections you might say hey 80 to 100
billion that's a huge number that's on
the order of the number of stars in a
milky way sized galaxy that's an
unimaginably large number but to kind of
blow your mind even more in the human
brain in the human brain there are
approximately 100
trillion
trillion synapses
synapses and another way to think about
them is let me write synapses
synapses or another way to think about
these are kind of the connections
between these hundred billion neurons or
these 80 to 100 billion yards so you're
thinking each neuron roughly has a
thousand connections to other neurons so
it's an incredibly incredibly complex
thing
so one question that might
you might say is okay well how how do
neurons relate to something
like
intelligence your ability to solve a
problem or to reason through things
and what we do know if you look at the
animal kingdom is that the amount of
neurons and the level of connections
between the neurons is a is a reasonable
indicator if you go from species to
species for intelligence so for example
jellyfish
have 800
800 neurons while human beings have 80
to 100 billion neurons that human beings
are kind of at the at the top of the
food chain at least when it comes to how
many neurons there are
and the the number of synapses etc kind
of go with that but what about within a
species can you can is is intelligence
something is intelligence that is
something that is fixed are you just
kind of born with a certain number of
neurons and a certain number of
connections between them or is it or is
it something that can somehow change
over time because of the environment
that you're in
and this is the interesting thing and
this is something that i'm i'm always
thinking about and it's fascinating and
i always think about it whenever i'm
when i'm thinking about things around
when i'm when i'm trying to tackle a new
subject is that there's actually a lot
of research here on the fact that you
can
change
you can change the structures in your
brain through training the structures in
your brain so you can change it
so this is
this is changeable
changeable or maybe i'll just
you can change it can
you can
change
your intelligence
based on essentially training your brain
and the analogy that you can have here
and you know you could say it's a
metaphor but in some ways it's a it's a
it's it's a very direct metaphor we all
know that you can train your muscles
that if you lift weights if you strain
your muscles
that then your muscle kind of your body
recognizes that it needs to be stronger
in that part of your body and it will
build that part of bodies as more you
strain it the more you stress it you
give it a little time for repair and
then your muscle will come back stronger
and what a lot of the researchers have
found over the last few decades is this
is also true of the brain
you see it as a child develops this is
this is some this is this is some
imagery that i got from mindset works
this is a site run by carol dweck who's
one of the researchers who really thinks
about how
the the uh how when you struggle and
when you try to tackle things more how
that affects your ability to actually
process it actually
affects your intelligence and what this
imagery right over here is this is a an
image of of a child's uh i guess you
could say
neuron density or the synapsal and
that's the word density at birth and we
see that as a child learns languages
they explore the world around them as
they struggle as they persevere as they
try to emulate those around them their
brain actually gets denser the more that
a child uses tries to kind of form
connection struggle stresses their brain
the connections between the neurons
become more numerous you see that here
and they can also become stronger so you
might you actually might have a a you
know once again more connections form
and they can become more active and when
you think about the brain as you know
when you have a thought it's all these
associations between these different
neurons and they're all firing and
stimulating each other what when you
build those new connections and those
new associations it a lot or those those
new synapses it allows you to form new
communication in your brain new new
associations it'll essentially allow you
to think faster and better and to reason
in ways that you couldn't have had done
before
and you might say okay well that just
happens from you know child to birth but
what about later on in life is this
something that i can change now if i'm
10 years old or 20 years old or 50 years
old and all the research says yes you
absolutely can and the key is how do you
stimulate your brain just as someone of
any age can stimulate their body and
allow their muscles to grow by lifting
weights by stressing them there's been
there have been many studies that have
shown for example in animals that if you
have an animal living in an
unstimulating environment you actually
don't have that many connections form
you don't have that much
density of the brain especially the
synapsal density but but then if you
have an animal that's in a stimulating
environment an environment that's
constantly challenging an environment
where it's interacting with each other's
and it's solving problems then you
actually have a higher density of of of
neural connections you have you
essentially the animal has become
smarter so what i find really
interesting about this and i always
remember it in my brain is
it's very easy you know a lot of us
it's it's tempting to say okay i got
what i got that's what my brain is and
you know i'll just have to deal with it
but what all the research tells us is
that is not the case the more you
stimulate the brain the more you
struggle the more you kind of try to
tackle new things you can actually train
train yourself let me see you can
actually train yourself to be
to be smarter whether you're smart or
not smart is not something that you were
just born with you can actually train
yourself and the best way to train
yourself and this it's it's very
analogous and there's a lot of research
here is very similar to the way that you
would train if you're lifting weights if
you're lifting weights if if you can
lift five pounds a lot you're not just
gonna keep lifting five pounds you wanna
push yourself you wanna try lifting
without you know consult your doctor or
your trainer you don't wanna blow out
your back or anything but you want to
keep lifting heavier and heavier weights
and essentially making your muscle
fatigue making your muscles struggle
it's not always an easy thing but it
pays off and the the when you train your
brain it's essentially the same thing
you want to tackle new problems you
don't want to tackle problems that are
easy but that's like lifting the two
pound weight over and over again you
want to lift the 10 pound weight the 20
pound weight to eventually get to the
100 pound weight and so that means
tackling problems doing problems that
are going to be difficult where you you
might make a mistake but making that
mistake is just like you know this
picture of arnold where maybe he's not
able to lift this weight but then as his
as his body kind of adjusts it won't
take too much time before he is able to
lift that
to lift that weight so the important
takeaways you can completely change your
intelligence by challenging yourself by
putting yourself in a stimulating
environment and your brain really is
like a muscle the more you train it the
more you struggle the more you stimulate
it the smarter you'll get